mission avec le sondeur du jour bonjour
stéphane zumsteeg merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce matin directeur du
département politique et opinion à
l'institut de sondage ipsos
on va parler longuement de votre sondage
sur paris mais d'abord un mot sur ce qu
aux navires us 1 l'ombre de l'épidémie
qui plane sur l'élection est ce que ça
fait de ce scrutin un scrutin à la forme
inédite alors c'était déjà un scrutin
qui s'annonçait inédit dans le sens où
jusqu'à présent on assistait toujours
soin des vagues reçoit des vagues bleues
et contenus de du changement du spectre
politique depuis depuis l'élection
présidentielle évidemment il n'y aura
pas de vague rose il n'y aura pas de
vague bleue il y aura surtout des maires
sortants qui seront élues ou qui seront
réélus mais c'est vrai que vient se
greffer là-dessus un autre élément bien
atypique extraordinaire d'une certaine
façon c'est ce coronavirus pour
l'instant on n'a pas dans les
différentes enquêtes que l'on a pu mener
on ne note pas une envie d'abstentions
ou d'absences d'intention d'aller voter
plus forte que d'habitude à cause du
coronavirus après dans les faits il ya
forcément une part marginale les
français qui refusera ou qui finalement
se sentira moins enclines à aller voter
que que traditionnellement pour
l'instant ce que l'on mesure c'est que
ce sera quelque chose à la marge à la
marge op avait pas de réel impact du
corona véreux sur ce scrutin sur la
participation et donc éventuellement sur
si ça peut être de un ou deux points ce
qui n'est pas rien ça se traduit par
quelques millions de francs en tout cas
plusieurs centaines de millions de
français pour l'instant il reste une
semaine et on est quand même dans une
s'apprête probablement a passé en stade
3 les choses là pour le coup l'opinion
peut changer ses comportements ou ses
intentions de comportement très
rapidement pour l'instant il n'ya pas
s'il n'y a pas ce sentiment il n'y a pas
cette impression que massivement les
français vont bouder les urnes pour des
raisons de sécurité allez on va balayer
à la campagne on va commencer par la
campagne à paris 1 puisque on va
regarder votre sondage c'est un sondage
ipsos oprah steria pour le figaro
sondage sur paris on va commencer par
les intentions de vote au premier tour
on va regarder ça avec anne hidalgo qui
est devant rachida dati mais d'un point
seulement 25% pour anne hidalgo 24 pour
rachida dati agnès buzyn troisième à 19%
un premier commentaire déjà sur les
intentions votre globale au premier tour
stéphane m'bia un chiffre qu'il faut
rappeler qui est qui à mon avis il
illustre bien comment les choses ont
évolué à paris il ya six ans 2014
au premier tour anne hidalgo et nathalie
kosciusko morizet qui représentait la
droite à l'époque obtient à toutes les 2
71% des suffrages au premier tour ce qui
est évidemment énorme
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on n'est
plus du tout dans cette configuration il
ya un émiettement une atomisation de
l'offre politique alors elle peut
s'expliquer effectivement par l'arrivée
de la république est en marche dans le
jeu politique ça n'existait que ce parti
n'existait pas il ya six ans mais aussi
des verts qui sont plus forts que
d'habitude il y à des candidats
dissidents je pense notamment à cédric
villani on le voit bien il ya deux
candidates pour l'instant qui font la
course en tête dans un mouchoir de poche
mais qui et c'est aussi très très
évocateur de des clivages qui peuvent
traverser l'opinion parisienne
finalement n'obtiennent que des scores
relativement limité
anne hidalgo est en tête c'est vrai mais
c'est la maire sortante c'était aussi la
favorite aujourd'hui sur la base des
différentes enquêtes que nous et nos
confrères peuvent publier mais
uniquement avec un quart des suffrages
exprimés donc course en tête mouchoir de
poche pour ces deux candidates et agnès
buzyn qui est quand même assez loin
derrière assez significativement loin
derrière avec 19 %
on voit bien c'est surtout la preuve
qu'il n'ya pas eu d'effets busin otoko
tout cas il n'a pas été aussi importants
que ce que les stratèges la république
en marche je pense pouvait l'espérer
quand ils ont décidé de la deûle a
choisi en fait pour remplacer benjamin
griveaux on voit bien ça n'a pas
fonctionné alors que le calcul était
très clair on voyait bien que le
benjamin griveaux est une personnalité
très clivante et n'arrivait pas à
attirer le vote de droite ou de centre
droit de l'ouest parisien des quartiers
qui entre qui traditionnellement vote à
droite mais qui avaient voté massivement
pour emmanuel macron et pour en 2017 et
pour nathalie l'oiseau en 2019
benjamin irez vous n'arrivez pas à
imprimer sa marque dans ces
arrondissements de droite dans l'ouest
parisien
le calcul était de faire avec son profil
sans doute plus compact et plus
centriste plus plus plus proche
finalement 2-2
on me dira de ces quartiers bourgeois
qui va traditionnellement centre-droit
au doigt agnès buzyn n'a pas réussi en
tout cas pour l'instant son pari de
biens de grignoter des voix cher et si
rachida dati
au contraire il ya eu un effet busin
dans le sens où elle a réussi en partie
à assécher la candidature de cédric
villani
on voit bien et encore quelques semaines
il était aux alentours de 13 14 15 % il
est maintenant sensiblement sous la
barre des 10%
c'est un effet plus entre sa très
clairement on voit bien ces gens là ne
voulaient pas voter c'est l'électorat
centriste proche de la république en
marche ne souhaitait pas voter pour des
raisons dites politiques ou personnelles
pour benjamin griveaux et donc
choisissez le candidat dissident
on voit bien les faits busin à
fonctionner dans ce cas bien précis
agnès buzyn a réussi à asphyxier en
partie la campagne de cédric villani et
c'est pour ça qu'il est maintenant dans
notre enquête à 7% en revanche ce qui ne
fonctionne pas pour l'instant c'est
cette tentative de captation des voix de
droite
bien au contraire puisque depuis
quelques semaines on assiste à une vraie
dynamique
en fait oui d'une certaine façon elle a
renforcé puisque finalement est là elle
est en passe en tout cas de gagner cette
première bataille du vote utile
on le voit bien anne hidalgo a
aujourd'hui auprès des parisiens un
bilan en demi teinte pour simplifier
selon les enquêteurs la moitié des
parisiens qui saluent son bilan et
l'autre moitié qui est qui qui
critiquent ce qui est ce qui n'est pas
par marlène d'ailleurs tu n'es fabrice
temps quand on le compare à ce que l'on
peut observer dans dans d'autres
enquêtes dont d'autres dans d'autres
villes on le voit bien millas est
finalement il ya cette volonté d'une
partie des parisiens de se séparer
d'anne hidalgo mais là tout se joue
maintenant sur la crédibilité sur le
vote utile est pour l'instant est bien
en tout cas ses électeurs de son du
centre ou du centre-droit font davantage
confiance et a réussi à capter le vol le
vote d'opposants finalement anne hidalgo
l'instant oui c'est en tout cas celle
qui est la plus crédible
un mot sur david bailey rwanda une bel
air il est donné à 12% dans votre
sondage c'est le candidat europe
ecologie les verts comment vous
expliquer le faible score des
écologistes à paris comparé à d'autres
métropoles à tout prendre c'est vrai que
donc de nombreuses vies on voit bien que
ils apparaissent comme la principale
force de gauche est aussi un chiffre il
faut rappeler il ya quelques mois le 26
mai dernier lors des élections
européennes europe écologie les
elle avait obtenu 20% des voix à paris
ce qui était évidemment considérable on
voit bien comment ça fonctionne moi ça
fonctionne beaucoup moins bien pourquoi
mais c'est aussi ce que l'on peut
comparer dans certaines villes de gauche
où il ya une forte incarnation on l'a
dans des villes comme rennes comme
nantes mais plus encore à paris mais on
voit bien qu'en tête quand il y a un
maire ou une mère de gauche qui se
représentent et qui dispose d'un bilan
en matière de lutte contre la pollution
qui a un positionnement écologistes
assez fort bien on voit bien que les
verts n'arrivent pas à tirer leur
épingle du jeu et quand on regarde là
aujourd'hui 25% pour pour anne hidalgo
deux fois moins pour david belliard ça
veut aussi dire que le match à gauche
toute la gauche
il est plié et que tout cet électorat
bobo cette fois ci du nord-est parisien
est bien votre a beaucoup plus
facilement pour anne hidalgo parce que
là encore il
cette opinion considère que son bilan en
ce qui concerne les questions
environnementales ou de place de la
voiture est globalement positif est que
les verts cela n'arrive pas à tirer leur
épingle du jeu
elle est justement on va regarder
ensemble deuxième tour là aussi votre
sondage largement devant à 42% rachida
dati à 33% agnès buzyn à 26
est ce que finalement anne hidalgo et
celles qui bénéficient d'un plus grand
d'une plus grande réserve de voix est ce
que le point faible de rachida dati
c'est sale a pas de réserve de voix pour
le second tour
oui à la pâte alliés n'a pas de réserve
de voix on a testé l'hypothèse promotion
la plus probable est celle d'une
triangulaire même si la situation sera
évidemment différente selon dans
certains arrondissements il ya des
maires divers droite qui se représentent
et qui ne soutiennent pas pour l'instant
rachida dati mais on voit bien oui les
réserves de voix ils sont clairement du
côté d'anne hidalgo vous parliez de
david bellion 12 % des voix on voit bien
dans les enquêtes que ces gens là votre
ont massivement au second tour s'il n'ya
ni alliance entre anne hidalgo et europe
ecologie les verts ces gens là c'est 12%
votre massivement très majoritairement
en faveur de la maire sortante et ça
c'est un réel avantage pour les
électeurs oui ce sera plus partagés déjà
parce que nous mesurons la france un
soumise à un niveau quand même bar 4%
c'est très peu donc ça pèse ça pèse peu
il ya une partie oui ceux qui iront
voter iront voter pour une hidalgo ne
voteront pas pour agnès buzyn ou pour
rachida dati évidemment mais on peut
aussi imaginer qu'une partie de cette
gauche radicale décide de rester à des
maisons de ne pas voter au second tour
malgré tout quand elle ira voter quand
ces gens là iront voter ce sera pour
anne hidalgo bien sûr alors dans vos
intentions second tour vous avez mis
année à l'eau plus fb lia rachida dati
tout seul et vous
agnès buzyn plus cédric villani pour
vous c'est ça qui se profile
en tout cas c'est pour l'instant
l'hypothèse la plus probable c'est des
villas ni peut-être un dissident enfin
il était encore il ya peu de temps
député de la république en marche et au
début de la campagne
en tout cas les choses étaient assez
clair en termes d'alliance de second
tour on verra bien ce que ça donnera ça
dépendra évidemment beaucoup du score de
cédric villani au premier tour 7 % c'est
peu ça veut aussi dire que pour faire
quand vous faites 7% en moyenne il ya
des arrondissements où il pourrait ne
pas franchir la barre des 5 % et on
rappelle la loi électorale si vous ne
faites pas 5% vous ne pouvez pas
fusionner avec avec une autre liste donc
ça peut avoir aussi des conséquences
importantes
donc malgré tout nous avons testé agnès
buzyn avec un ralliement de cédric
villani
quand on regarde pas alors ça c'est une
chose sont les ralliements politiques
entre personnalités entre têtes de liste
en revanche quand on regarde ensuite les
comportements électoraux les gens qui
comptent voter pour cédric villani on
voit bien que les choses ne vont pas
forcément aller de soi il ya à peu près
dans cette dernière enquête
la moitié des électeurs de cédric
villani qui compte en cas de ralliement
voté pour agnès buzyn de ça veut aussi
dire que la moitié de cet électorat ira
ailleurs s'abstiendra ou votre a
notamment pour pour anne hidalgo un
petit peu pour rachida dati ça veut
partager mais c'est aussi parce que
c'est un électorat extrêmement
hétéroclites
cédric villani une personnalité un peu
particulière - politique - politicienne
peut-être que celle de daniel busin de
rachida dati et d'anne hidalgo
ces gens là viennent un peu de partout
et repartiront un peu partout au second
tour
et à la question qui se pose d'une
éventuelle alliance entre agnès buzyn et
rachida dati pour faire tomber nidal go
alors agnès buzyn fait paraître un
communiqué hier en disant que les choses
soient claires il n'y aura pas
d'alliance d'appareils au soir du
premier tour en train de s'amuser et
rachida dati
qu'en est il du côté des électeurs est
ce que les électeurs d'agnès busan sont
prêts à voter rachida dati au second
tour et inversement
alors là pour le coup on comprend on
comprend à nice besoin qui d'abord par
le d'absence totale de stratégie de
ralliement parce que le but évidemment
d'arriver en tête ou en tout cas
d'arrivée devant rachida dati au premier
tour
tout est dans le sa réponse pas
d'alliance d'appareils d'un jeu déjà il
y aura des situations particulières dans
des xvème arrondissement dans les 16ème
arrondissement xviie arrondissement un
certain nombre de candidats divers
droite seront peut-être tenter de
rallier la candidature d'agnès busin
plutôt que celle de rachida dati à voir
mais tout semble le sera évidemment que
que le lundi ou le mardi suivant le
premier taux serait évidemment fonction
du résultat électoraux du niveau des
électorale des dessins et des autres
maintenant pour revenir sur le souhait
de tel ou tel électorat d'alliance très
clairement quand on voit aujourd'hui
quelle est la composition sociologique
du vote d'à république en marche
faut pas oublier une chose en 2017 au
premier tour emmanuel macron obtient 24
% des voix en france il ya plus de gens
de gauche que de droite qui votent pour
lui alors effectivement le centre de
gravité de la macro ni c'est un petit
peu déplacé vers la droite en deux ans
et demi trois ans c'est vrai mais s'il y
avait une alliance formelle entre agnès
buzyn rha dit rachida dati je pense que
les conséquences électorales de toute
cette partie de ses électeurs encore de
gauche ou de centre gauche serait
évidemment catastrophique pour la
république en marche non ils n'en
veulent pas pour répondre clairement à
votre question on va regarder les deux
derniers les deux derniers panneaux de
votre sondage vous avez demandé qui
ferait un bon maire et là c'est
extrêmement serrée entre les trois de
favorite
anne hidalgo 48% rachida dati 48% et
agnès buzyn 47%
ce qui était important avant tout ce
sont les niveaux sont des niveaux
extrêmement faibles pourquoi parce que
les choses sont très clivée à paris on
peut aimer fin quand on teste la images
la popularité de candidates comme
rachida dati ou anne hidalgo et bien les
résultats sont un petit peu les mêmes
parce que eh bien les gens de gauche ont
une bonne image d'anne hidalgo mais une
trés les gens de droite une très
mauvaise très mauvaise image d'alice la
même chose al'inverse pour rachida dati
les choses sont très très clivée c'est
pour ça aussi que bon elles sont dans un
mouchoir de poche sur ces questions là
mais plus important encore que cette non
différence au niveau de 48% sa ligne aux
normes anormalement bas dans d'autres
villes cantons à nancy les principaux
candidats feraient un bon ou un mauvais
mais revient vous avez des scores de 60
70 % parfois d'approbation on voit bien
qu'on est dans des bien loin aujourd'hui
à paris et on va regarder ce dernier
panneau qui est très intéressant c'est
anne hidalgo qui bénéficie de la plus
grande notoriété
jusque là c'est plutôt logique c'est la
maire sortante 97 % devant rachida dati
96 et agnès buzyn 92 mais vous avez
demandé qui bénéficie de la meilleure
opinion et là surprise c'est cédric
villani qui arrive en tête avec 50 %
devant hidalgo agnès buzyn égalité à 48
comment on explique ce paradoxe villani
parce que son image est moins
politicienne en fait que les autres et
là encore ce que je disais les gens de
gauche n'aime pas rachida dati les gens
de droite n'aime pas anne hidalgo
les gens qui n'aiment pas emmanuel
macron n'aime pas agnès buzyn cédric
villani là une chance et que finalement
il ne suscite pas de projet particulier
ou voire de haine particulière
donc oui il ya un paradoxe il est plutôt
bien vu enfin plus exactement il est
mieux ou moins mal vu que c'est pour
être plus exact mais ça ne se traduit
pas électoralement aller